what are we looking at the projection
yes i remember this very well
all right everybody
i'll have quiet i will have quiet
oh i'll have quiet
do you think he'll have quiet i think
he'll have quiet
hey conor o'brien here for another
edition of behind the nonsense
uh this is basically segments where we
go behind the scenes on sketches find
out uh how they were made why they were
made and is there any way we can go back
in time and have them not made
anyway
i'm sitting here with one of our writers
skyler higley hey skyler hi did you or
did you not maybe the second time we
spoke great did you or did you not refer
to me as an old [ __ ] well
short answer yes
but you look you keep putting me in a
position where you say i'm bullying you
and then i have to bully you yeah yeah
that's what happened you heard from all
the other writers
conan's a madman he's insane but in all
the time you've worked with me in all of
our meetings you've seen nothing but
maybe the sanest guy you've ever met and
a a professional and a gentleman and a
scholar
and i only have positive things to say
well listen as an old [ __ ]
to a young man i just want to say my my
best to you uh we're going to look at a
piece now this is a a bridgerton piece
it was announced that the star
can you call him a star yeah you could
call him the star i mean he's the
breakout the star why do you say his
name again regains on page okay regain
jean-page uh breakout star
ladies going crazy for this guy
and uh the fellas too i know i'm in that
camp and everyone loves him he denounced
he was leaving and so uh you had a
concept for maybe
a new replacement is that fair to say
yeah i think i could do it okay
well let's see how that worked out let's
take a look
some big news
just came out about bridgeton uh reggae
jean page will not be reprising the role
of simon bassett
wow that he's like the breakout star of
that show that's a big deal yeah yeah
and he's not coming back wow
fans are freaking out
and uh it's all over the internet
everybody's freaking out about it and
then i hear one of our writers
apparently has something he wants to say
about this
i don't know what it is but i should
give him a chance to speak so let's talk
to him now please welcome skyler higley
schuyler are you there
oh hey conan
oh what a jacket this these are just my
regular clothes i wear every day but i
guess you're right i do look like the
perfect replacement for rage on paige
no i i never said i don't think i said
it all that you should replace reggae
jean-page
well then why did i tell everyone you
did conan i don't know why you told
people that
don't tell people that
look skylar it's a huge role on a huge
show do you have any kind of acting
experience at all yes conan i already
have about what 15 seconds of on-screen
experience and i'm already killing it i
wouldn't say you're killing it you're
just chatting with me
uh
look this is a demanding role that
requires serious acting skills can you
even do a british accent
of course check this out oi blimey
governor
it's me simon bassett mayor of
bridgerton
here to fornicate with you no one says i
want to fornicate with you
no one would ever say i want here to
fornicate with you
make sweet love
no no no
open your nickel no no not in up in
anyone's knickers that was terrible i
don't know cohen it sounds like you're
jealous you know when i do this accent
people say i sound like the british
idris elba so idris elba is british
okay conan by the way i took the lorry
to my flat where i ate some fish and
chips and did some colonizing oh yeah
yeah okay yeah
that's what people say i'm gonna go do
some colonizing skyler even if they
looked past your horrible british accent
i have to tell you this is a very highly
sexualized role
i get that and i think i'm mature enough
to work around boobies so
spoken like a real authorial yeah look
ray gage on page is a heartthrob women
love this guy yeah yeah i get it he's
handsome but you know maybe the
character could be funny i could make
everyone horny with humor okay and how
would you do that
oh easy check this out
let's have sex
okay
no one's going to like that uh actually
i'm kind of turned down by that all
right look skyler you're a very funny
writer terrific writer but you're not
gonna replace reggae jean-page it's not
gonna happen well
i guess there's only one thing to say to
that conan
[Music]
you've crushed my dreams
and that means you okay hey
how was
that all right
yes you've got the part clearly because
you're so sexy and the slide whistle is
just driving women nuts
wow nothing says reggae jean page like
that sound one of the things that people
need to understand when they look at
that is that you were in chicago at the
time that was in was that were you in
your apartment with the incredibly low
ceiling
uh yes that was the low ceiling
apartment yeah every time i would talk
to you or you would do anything for us
you would come to us from your uh
chicago apartment and you'd be sitting
down behind the desk and the ceiling of
your apartment even when you were
sitting was pressed down on top of your
head
but so you have to do that over zoom
and i can't think of a harder thing to
do than to do comedy with somebody else
and you're in chicago and i'm in la and
it's zoom and there's a pandemic going
right i mean there's a delay and there's
like uh yeah it's hard to you know
you're like i'm just in front of a
screen and now i'm looking straight at
you the whole time instead of like the
way we actually talk to each other which
is sometimes i look at you and sometimes
i don't then you're just like in my face
all the time and who wants conan
directly in their face at all times i i
uh listen a lot of people were killed
and look at me constantly i know i'm
noticing that i'm looking at you the
whole time and you keep looking away
nervously
yeah well
just making you nervous what i'm doing
right now no i'm incredibly turned on
that's what incredibly turned on people
say and that's just also the way they
say it how do we get you the outfit for
that because that was the other thing i
remember being impressed that that idea
was hatched very late and i think did
scott cronic send you
he like fedexed you that outfit yeah
they overnighted me that outfit and what
you don't see of the outfit was i mean
most of it because it was a zoom window
but there was like a whole uh there was
like a whole pants part to it that and
these like high boots and uh it had this
whole lapel it really looked like a real
bridgeton
outfit i was very impressed um you can't
see two thirds of it yeah you can't see
most of it but i you know i walked down
the street and just kind of looked at
people you you walked past wrigley field
and i walked like this because that's
how you walk in a suit like that yes
back in 1780. if you want to get a
message out to anyone uh out there in
the world about just what an incredible
i don't know
feeling there is on the conan show
the respect and reverence i show
all of you writers maybe now is the time
to say
it i wasn't told that this part was
gonna happen um i'm just going with it i
just thought maybe i could get something
on film no like so i could make a
statement um i would say
whatever he said that
i should say about him yeah is what i
say okay well skyler thank you very much
yeah thank you thank you for calling me
the greatest influence in your life ever
we're going to insert that later
yeah and i'll say that thank you skyler
yeah you're a scholar and a gentleman
[Music]
wait no but let me just like say it so
then you could like feed it in with a
different voice okay
and so in post oh we know what to do
yeah we know exactly what to do the only
praise i've ever gotten has been when i
make people move their lips and then add
it later on in post conan's a mad old
[ __ ]